Let's look at the solution
to our Raid4 quiz.
We have a Raid4 array with five disks.
And one disk has 200 GB in capacity.
The data capacity of the array is
the data capacity of all but one disk.
Because we sacrifice
a single disk to parity.
So among the five disks one is
parity the other ones contain data.
So we have four times this
much which is 800 gigabytes.
The throughput of the array for
reads is going to be the throughput
of the four data disks.
So we have 40 megabytes per
second throughput for reads.
But for writes, it's going to be half
a throughput of a single disk and that's
because the parity disk need to be
both read and written for every write.
So, we get five megabytes
per second here.
So now we need to figure out
what happens during one second.
Well, this throughput is eight
times the throughput of the writes.
Which means in every
given second one-ninth
of a second will be spent on reads.
And eight-ninths of a second
will be spent on writes.
That way we spent eight times as
much time on writes as we do for
reads, which allows us to do
the same number of reads and writes.
So now the overall throughput
will be what we can read in
one-ninth of a second plus what we can
write in eight-ninths of a second.
And that ends up being
80 over 9 megabytes.
So this is what we can do in a second.
So our average throughput ends up
being 8.89 megabytes per second.
Again, just like in our Raid1 quiz, we
cannot simply average the throughput for
reads and the throughputs for writes.
We would get something more than 20
megabytes a second if we do that.
But that would do a lot more reads than
writes, because it assumes that half
a second we are reading, and
we managed to read 20 megabytes, and
then half a second we are writing,
and managed to write 2.5 megabytes.
As you can see, the read to
write ratio is not 50/50 here.
So that is, again, why, we get this, and
not just a simple average of these two.
So the final question
here is what's the MTTF?
We know that the MTTF of RAID4 is
equal to the MTTF of 1 disk squared
divided by N, times N-1 times the time
it takes us to replace a disk.
Our N in this case is 5 so
we get 5 x 4 times the s.
And in this expression
again this is the time
that we get to work with the full RAID4
array until we have a failed disk.
And this is how many times we
survived the repair without
the second disk failing.
The overall number is
20,833,333.33 hours,
which, again, much better than this.
And we already said that this
is about 11 to 12 years.
This is more then 2,000 years.
Remember that our RAID1 had 20,000
years, so this is significantly worse
than RAID1, but on the other hand we
are working with 5 disks here and
spending only one-fifth of
our capacity on parity.
With Raid 1,
we were working with only two disks, and
spending half of the capacity
of the array on parity.
So we sacrifice some MTTF to
get better cost per gigabyte.
But we still achieve a very,
very high MTTF.